et pour revenir sur la colère des
avocats nous sommes avec david libeskind
avocat au barreau de paris co fondateur
du collectif robe noir et gilet jaune
david libeskind bonsoir merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation direction rt
france peut-être un mot sur cet acte 62
des gilets jaunes du monde d'aujourd'hui
où des échauffourées alors il ya
beaucoup de monde parce que c'était un
appel national donc beaucoup de
provocations sont descendus au monté
pour manifester à paris énormément de
monde je faire des milliers de personnes
parlent eu effectivement des
échauffourées la police a beaucoup gaz
et de manière gratuite parce qu'il n'y a
pas eu vraiment en tant que tel pas en
tout cas à cet incident de violence à
l'encontre des forces de l'ordre donc
elles ont gazés malheureusement il des
blessés à peu près 10 interpellé des
zags d'interpeller l'un des actions
aussi beaucoup d'actions ces derniers
jours de votre profession donc les les
avocats une grève un qui était prolongé
d'une semaine
est-ce que les autres professions les
avocats est ce que vous allez pouvoir
tenir dans le temps pour obtenir ce
retrait de la réforme des retraites
on espère on espère qu'on va leur
revenir l'entente parce que c'est quand
même ce qui nous est proposé n'est pas
du tout admissibles puisque puisque ça
change d'ailleurs concrètement un bain
concrètement c'est assez simple déjà à
doubler la cotisation sociale
des avocats qui perçoivent un revenu
annuel de 40000 euros brut 1
on dit souvent quarante mille membres on
précise max & broad c'est un chiffre
d'affaires et leur cotisation va passer
de 14 à 28 % ce qui fait que de nombreux
petits cabinets malheureusement vont
fermer ça c'est un premier point et
deuxième point on reste que
malheureusement d'assister à
l'augmentation des honoraires au
détriment des justiciables en fait s'il
répond qu'il n'est ni bonne pour les
avocats ni bonne pour les justiciables
est ce que finalement le niveau de vie
des avocats n'est pas surévalué par
l'opinion publique
6 mais ça c'est le mythe de l'avocat qui
a beaucoup d'argent mais c'est plus du
tout le cas aujourd'hui
moi il ya quelques années j'avais bu un
soda je crois que les avocats perçoivent
en moyenne 3000 euros par mois surtout
les avocats de province les avocats en
province il ya beaucoup d'avocats en
province et dans les banlieues
parisiennes qui vivent que de l'aide
juridictionnelle et comment ces deux
montants qui sont alloués aux avocats
concernant l'aide juridictionnelle
c'est pas du tout admissible le projet
du gouvernement ne peut pas accepter le
ce projet justement est-ce que vous en
êtes dans vos discussions avec le
gouvernement en particulier avec la
garde des sceaux nicole belloubet alors
il ya la présidente
du conseil national des barreaux
inquiets notre organe représentatif de
la profession
il ya les discussions qui vont continuer
à se tenir mais il est hors de question
que on abandonne notre régime notre
propre propre régime qui coûte zéro euro
aux français parce que c'est un régime
propre cas excédentaire et on verse tous
les ans 115 millions d'euros à l'état
donc les discussions avant se continuent
et vont continuer il est hors de
question que les avocats soient soient
pénalisés quoi comment vous expliquer
cette difficulté de dialoguer d'entrer
en dialogue avec le gouvernement sur
cette question sur votre profession plus
particulièrement vincent quand monsieur
macron était ministre de l'économie il
avait déjà bull j'aurais pu former la
profession ça n'a pas marché
je pense que le président de la
république et le gouvernement ont une
forme de mépris à l'encontre de la
profession d'avocat je ne serais vous
dire pourquoi ça c'est certain mais le
dialogue va se continuer puis on espère
que ça va aboutir à quelque chose de
concret et positif pour tous les avocats
de france
justement quelle est la suite des
événements désormais jusqu'où ira le
bras de fer avec l'exécutif selon bat le
bras de fer lille ira jusqu'à alors
peut-être pas le retrait de la réforme
bon au moins qu'on puisse quand même
négocié cette réforme afin qu'ils
puissent s est situé à un vrai dialogue
social et palm est pas au détriment des
avocats merci beaucoup de gens qui
vivent à skins d'avoir accepté notre
invitation directe ur est étrange rappel